[Applause]
oh you can perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody I am Thomas
topazole whatever you want to call me
this is the dope as usual podcast I'm
here with my co-host Marty O'Neill
what's up guys what up we're gonna hop
right into this this podcast the double
cheese products about life drugs
problems accomplishments and everything
in between today we have a very special
guest I'm hyped let's get started this
is the ad episode thank you for being
here man appreciate you man appreciate
you man thank you for being here thank
you for coming and bringing the vibe and
I'm excited to sit down and talk man
I've been watching you for a while man
yeah oh yeah we didn't talk about good
[__] thank you I've been watching it for
a while so you know I was like when he
hits you up you're doing what you're
supposed to be doing yeah man nice man
that's good to hear it
um real quick I I kind of feel dumb with
eight minutes before you got here go
he's from Compton right so
Compton ad
and I felt so stupid
I felt so good you ain't gotta feel dumb
man knock I'm like yo it's just a a
space in between and I didn't put it
together human being you were like
honesty
that's dope though just say I'm like the
the artist you know because I know you
as a podcast I know you as a podcast I
know you you're online you're with uh
Juno and you guys are doing your [__]
and I'm like and then he's like he makes
music go and you put God I feel so
stupid right now you know what but I I
really like I like that and I appreciate
that because a lot of people you know I
mean felt the same type of way they like
this can't be the same guy because you
know like me coming up in music I I was
doing Street Music you know what I mean
so a lot of times like people would like
you know just the conversation we was
having um off air was you don't know
who's looking at you people don't know
because the type of content that you put
out there oh maybe it's not cool to even
ask this guy for a picture maybe you
know what I'm saying they were they were
prejudging and I'm like dang I want
people to come take a picture of me and
stuff like that get that different vibe
yeah yeah once I started showing my
personality on the podcast and stuff
like that people just like either didn't
know or did like oh this is a great guy
you know what I mean so it's just
Bridging the two together but same guy
man same package I just felt so like
because I have been to a show and then
it's a company all right and then I
remember Compton has Terry from Jackass
I'm like I never heard nobody confidence
man
sad road right now I mean we talked
about it a couple months ago yeah that's
unfortunate the weirdest little like for
real
in your 40s whoa whoa
give me the man for 30 years than that
life man
life can you know got all type of twists
and turns it can hit you so sad man it's
probably just a dumb argument with the
homies like let's hit
don't isn't it always that way though
yeah
that's usually what I can always say
like all these fools get in trouble or
fighting each other shooting that [__]
like I guarantee but you like that show
oh me too I [__] with you you're cool
how many times I've gotten like I know
your brother you know that oh you know
my yeah we're friends it's just such a
like a changing Stone yeah I feel like
that but those guys are homies the the
you know I'm talking about the Harry
Kennedy yeah thing that I
yeah that was sad I don't really know
too much about it uh badass skater him
and his homie got an altercation they
fought for his head and that was it oh
gosh yeah he's getting charged with it
oh God I didn't really murdered so he
fell backwards he was having the
concrete they were fighting and he died
from it yeah wow
it's terrible terrible terrible you're
not gonna think from a fight then
someone's gonna ah with your homie I'm
like full all right tomorrow we'll make
a text me for all right yeah sad sad
Road dude yeah sorry it's getting on the
uh all right so Compton all right you're
from out here how old are you 34 oh 89
yeah oh okay same yeah um
so you grew up in my era obviously same
thing but you grew up down here I grew
up you know where Fresno is of course
okay I'm from Merced like the little
town by a little [__] town it's like the
little you know ghetto agriculture towns
snowed out there
no I know it snows are Fresno it did
once when I was a kid but like the light
this light sprinkle [__] no it's high
it's like 108 right now yeah it's those
methods that's a good way to put it
Marty
um so growing up
you're in the 90s the same age as me I
gotta ask because I feel like a lot of
people don't ask people like you said is
he is he kind of guy we can go back to
you can ask me anything but then people
don't realize like when you walked in
and go so if we pay a pickup game he's
in he's on our team for a while right
this guy's on our side right did you
play sports as a kid no well I mean what
listen I did like as a as a small child
but my ambitions was never to like I
didn't have hoop dreams or like no not
even football basketball none of that
how many coaches approach you every day
I mean that's what people always used to
say my uncle too he said black man you
should have played football nothing yeah
that's not what I expected I didn't know
I mean maybe when I was like I think I
think I played
basketball baseball and football from a
span of like eight to like 11 or 12 and
I was like this [__] ain't for me oh
that's different okay
and then my high school didn't have a
football team so I probably would have
had football I would have probably would
have played football if I would have
went to a different High School school
King Drew
they don't have a football team nope
due to what like funds no they got money
they had like a great basketball team
but it was like no football field
oh no that's the sign where I'm from in
New York that's a sign your school is
going down the [__] oh yes they start
cutting the sports well you heard of
Drew League that's where the Drew league
is oh no [__] so they ain't missing out
on no money man oh damn that's pretty
cool that's all you you know you know
about that yeah yeah when you're when
you're uh instruments start getting
taken away that's what I was like damn
the schools tonight on my school
remember we had to buy our own I'm out
we can't afford a trumpet these stupid
ass we live over here that's crazy I had
music class in seventh grade would you
play
I want to say it was the saxophone
but the I still got this mark on my hand
because the music board fell down and
like sliced with that seventh grade yeah
the little metal thing yeah yeah damn
they just told me you got to come in on
Saturday for practice tonight turned my
[__] in the next day damn I'm not giving
you a Saturday I don't want to be here
on Monday that's crazy uh do you smoke
yeah all right all right OG or lemon
what do you want to start with let me
hit the lemon man all right it's [__]
fire it's my favorite weed right now
this is you no no this is my favorite
meal no he's a goddamn kind of soup and
you have a you should have a lighter
right next to you too baby getting on me
for a fake smoking but I ain't gonna
fake smoke today with me puffing
just do a little bit because I'll be
trying to keep my mind right A lot of
times I go blank when I just be like
high as [__] yeah what happened we
realized no more mushrooms when we're
interviewing and I do oh for reals oh I
can't do that I was doing something
yesterday I just wasn't into the
conversation we did too much yeah you
live streamed with the two though right
mushrooms yes but I like I like the
micro dose first time I'm gonna take one
or like at the most two squares and see
chocolates yeah the chocolates see how I
feel
and then if I get to three always
[Laughter]
but it's a fun time though what's the
most monsters you ever read that one
because you're big that was the most
three oh micro dose just the micro dose
and so what are those like half cramps
well honestly when I first started I had
two bad trips and it scared me for a
long time real shrooms or chocolate real
shrooms but I was in the club and that's
not the right
like the first two or three times that
you do streams you don't want to be in
the nightclub you know what I'm saying
you know everyone's intentions you don't
know what that feeling is like and then
you know you feel the boom boom You Feel
The Beat I'm like I'm having a heart
attack am I having a stroke the lights
is crazy the room feels like it's just
caving in and stuff too so I couldn't do
that I did that I did that two times I
stopped for a long time and I was like
you know what let me go into this with a
with a clear mindset and I love it now
yeah I love it have you have you have
you eaten enough to catch the crazy 100
visuals I have some um penis envies now
I'm kind of I'm contemplating on uh
taking those because I heard those that
are most potent you do them
alone I might freak myself out
or find some stuff out
oh
about yourself I don't like how he said
find some stuff I usually do streams in
the pitch black by myself in the dark
but how did you feel though incredible
like you man you know when you're
located you're like damn imagining all
this [__] he's talking about seven grams
though yeah but like a lot like that
those big doses but if you think about
it like everything in your brain comes
out because you can't see
so imagine tripping in the dark it's
only your brain and you and it's [__]
I just literally watched this YouTuber
yesterday
and he did like I think it was
close to three grams but he said it felt
like seven
and he documented like his whole trip
but he said it's like super close to
being on DMT that's what everyone told
me that's what I don't want to do I'm
down I just I'm down for that I'm
nervous have you gotten I've gone to
where I'm out of my body looking down on
my body tripping flying around the
neighborhood
so like I want to know what DMT is after
that little [__] you just you just
really scared me now that [__] I don't
want to look at my body
you ever watch Peter Pan I think I'm
dead and he's flying around yeah [__]
that mean a ghost that shit's tight you
probably was dying bro you was coming
right back I was good [__] crazy I just
like uh I just like unexplainable [__]
like you know what I'm saying like I
can't believe my brain did that see me
so as my body start tingling any type of
way
that's why I don't [__] with Edibles oh
really the body high
you know I can't [__] with all like that
it's hard to get up
yeah
that [__] is uh I feel like I eat
shitload Edibles though but
it just depends on you know how your
body processes it you're a big dude and
still hit you like that it's just your
it's just your tolerance and the way
your brain like you know
I think the anxiety of it
it's 90 of it makes you paranoid
which in turn you know what I'm saying
hit you a different type of way and
you're freaking out yeah so the same way
like with mushrooms when I just say you
know what I know that I'm about to go
through a trip I'm cool I'm safe it's no
problem I always have a good time so
maybe I need to eat Edibles and go
through that the same exact way maybe
just don't like the body eyes you know
what I'm saying no I feel you I don't
like the head high I like the body high
see I can prefer the head high I don't
like when I'm like I turn it's like a
little slower yeah oh you're talking
about the quicksand like slow motion
yeah that's just too much for me man
everything is a little harder to do yeah
I'm already tired that [__] doesn't make
make it more fun
um when did you start smoking though
um for the first time when I was 21
years old wow yeah it really held out
now because um my grandma she used to
smoke cigarettes as a kid and she should
get like
go through packs and packs of them I
hated the smell like it's just that put
a bad taste in my mouth when it came
down to just you know smoking and my
granny ended up getting cancer
twice so that was another part of her I
was just like I don't think I want to
ever smoke and stuff like that and um
shout out to my homie GMAC he was like
man hit this weed one day man I was like
man [__] it he drove to granny house I
went outside started smoking with him
got paranoid but I was like all right
man this is part of the part of the game
and [__] too but then being around like
a lot of my homeboys and [__] like that
and them doing it all day every day then
I start building a tolerance for it but
I was always more of a drinker though
okay even like dude because you said 21
so all through high school you're the
only do not smoking basically hey but
but it was it wasn't because like it
drugs no smoke
I mean living in Compton
I was always taught like you don't want
to be on nothing you want to watch your
surroundings you don't want nothing
that's going to you know what I'm saying
that Split Second can be the the
difference between your life or not so
you know when I'm going outside and I'm
sitting in cars and stuff my head is on
the swivel I'm not trying to be
intoxicated in any type of you know I'm
saying way yeah to feel that way too so
you know that was that was most of the
reason why
so growing up as a kid what are you
getting into you're not smoking but your
head's out of swivel you're into some
[__] I'm in the street [__] man just you
know
just not really having no Role Models
growing up like that and honestly when
you grow up in a neighborhood you don't
even try to like join this street [__]
you know what I'm saying a lot of times
people are born into it but like when
all your homeboys that you play
basketball with down the street and you
did all type of stuff when they started
doing their thing and going and turning
and stuff like that then it becomes like
okay these are my friends slash family
people [__] with them it's just like
they [__] with me I might as well you
know what I'm saying join my guys that
I've been [__] with my whole life
anyway so yeah I'm Association type of
thing yeah yeah always though but I mean
I hate to say this and it's and it's bad
that it's in our community like that but
a lot of times the kids who don't join
anything get [__] with the most yeah
so you know it's like a real survival
thing especially when you go into your
neighborhood every day and people peer
pressure in you and you know what I'm
saying this is crazy
well I read a horrible story and an
interview with you where you talked
about one of your friends on your porch
well my porch wasn't Affiliated or
nothing don't say man Dante Jackson Man
Dottie B yeah that was you know what's
crazy was that was the first time
in my life that I was like all right I
felt like an adult and I feel like
shit's real now
like high school was over with none of
that cool like this is like real life is
hitting you and you got to go through
the motions and [__] like that because
after that happened
funeral after funeral after funeral is
just non-stop and I you know I end up
just getting numb to it and you know
even to this day like death don't hit me
the same way that it you know it will
hit other people and [__] like that you
know what I'm saying so
do you have any advice like we've both
lost a lot of people you know we have a
younger audience do you have any advice
for kids out there losing hella people
on how to not let yourself spiral yeah
just you know get your mental health
right try to channel that energy into
something that's positive that's gonna
you know get you out of the situation
that you're in that was my whole thing
like music was always the goal of of
just okay this is going to be my vehicle
that gets me out of this area and that
changes my life you know what I'm saying
so you know you just got to find and all
of us we got hidden talents people don't
like to explore them or they may feel
like oh it's corny people may talk about
me like nah it comes with what's
naturally good to you it's there for a
reason you know what I'm saying God
ain't put it in your put it in you if it
if it wasn't supposed to be like that so
don't be afraid to explore what makes
you great no matter what nobody says and
then like we always say something
different might happen fast forward now
podcasting exists and you got your own
[__] and that's even that's even what
happened for me like I didn't know like
I didn't have no play hands on doing
this or like dreaming for it or anything
and this is a super big part of my
identity now which I'm very grateful for
the people that [__] with me and
everything too so yeah man you don't
never know where God's gonna take you
and that's why I like to tell myself
every day like have unwavering Faith you
feel me and I'm just gonna let
let them take me where he's supposed to
take me I think I think everybody has
their own version of that I think it's
supposed to be what happens for a re my
thing is like
nothing could have changed that nothing
you could have did no matter what stop
and tie my shoe what I like 10 seconds
later or maybe I wouldn't have ran to
that guy like everybody thinks that [__]
and it's just there's nothing to do
there's nothing you could do just roll
with it and hopefully it comes out the
best as long as you try I think a lot of
it is a energy attracts energy we've
talked about this a lot that's real I
had a lot of homies that they just they
[__] a lot and it's like bro there's a
reason why your shit's not going well
all you do is talk about other people
that's a big thing talking about other
people too much it brings on in a you
wasted part of your day talking about
people you don't like you know I mean I
think that happens a lot and it's
associate yourself with yes Association
of a Company You Keep hundred percent
you're hanging around a gang of winners
you're gonna be that next winner hanging
around a gang of losers you're gonna
follow right behind that and if you get
out of the gang of losers now you're the
one that's different and you're changing
it's like no I'm just trying to make it
better for all of us which is fine yeah
and you're in that transition too
probably homies and shit's like I'm not
oh bro I'm trying to build it it's
always it's always a line and my thing
is is that like I know the street life
is really a trick bag you know I mean
there's really not a lot of ways that
you could successfully uh do that come
on on top yeah I mean just look at
history people don't come out on top no
so you know to the younger kids and
stuff it's a trick bag and to my
homeboys you know once I started like
experiencing different things and
traveling and really opening my eyes and
seeing the bigger picture
they will call me hey if this happened
I'd be like man call me if you got some
positive to do call me you feel me if
you got like a business something you
want to start anyway we could do that
call me if it's some [__] call
somebody else
and that's always you know the part that
I felt like I played being a role model
for my for my homeboys and you know the
people that's coming up like okay you
could come from this place but they
don't have to Define you in the moves
that you make throughout your life
exactly I'm trying to be the mayor of my
town one day you know what I mean like
just wild just I don't know if I want to
be in America oh I'm my small town my
small town for sure I won't be the mayor
I'm gonna clean that [__] up
uh our Town's full of meth heads it's
it's just it's what it is
just what it is man I always wondered
you know like uh San Andreas is my
favorite game all time CJ growing up in
[__] New York and [__] where are you
guys actually in growing up in Compton
living through all that [__] that those
that game and games like that are like
based upon were you ever offended like
these [__] made a game out of
this [__] going around like nah it was
more of a joy yeah especially when it
came out because it's like oh [__]
they're in LA and it's basically like
representing you know what that was at
that time and stuff too like yeah I
couldn't wait for that game to come out
you know I mean it's even playing that
like it was real it did a good job they
did a very good job yeah and they did a
real good job yeah I said that's an
angle I never thought about Marty well I
mean yeah you might grow up in this game
remember they would scan walls and put
the taggings from the walls yeah on the
game
so I guarantee there's some graph
writers out there like bro
you know I mean they probably have a
screenshot and print it out all further
and like we had Franklin on here like he
was saying like yeah cast real people
that is a [__] good point like they
cast his cousin to CJ like actual people
from there to base the characters on it
shuts up that's fine so damn yeah you're
all right it's different when you're
you're the exact same age all right so
we could talk about some stuff random I
don't think people probably ask
and that's what this this show's about
let's do it all right this is the
question we asked because one day I was
at home like
nah I probably get my eyes beat 16 year
old you walks in okay hyped up ready to
fight you win or he win the 16 year old
I'm beating a 16 year old there you go
instant for sure all right I got a lot
of people I do knows I probably would
like jumped me that's his answer like me
and my friends would have jumped me if
16 year old me he's like I'm gonna get
beat up right now that's why I was like
There's different questions like me it's
like
he getting [__] up all right what are
you telling 16 year old you right now
um I wasn't gonna say stay in school but
I didn't stay in school [__]
[Music]
not even for academics just speeding be
there no I probably tell them man hey
keep going you're gonna be all right
yeah
that's all I needed if you got ambition
that's really all you need like don't
don't worry
life is going to be terrible for you
it's going to be nothing but struggles
don't don't talk to her she's gonna
cheat on you and you're like nah
uh are you an only child no oh oh oh oh
oh so you got how many
you just went no
I want to say six brothers oh [__] yeah
where you fall in line in that oldest
youngest middle no I'm my mom's oldest
my daddy's uh second oldest yeah I got
like a uh my little my youngest brother
was four right now or yeah damn my young
brother's nine same age as my son wow oh
so my son got an uncle his age me too my
uncle Carlos that's awesome
all right so you know what it's like so
you're growing up you're the oldest are
you the oldest boy though yeah this is
the oldest my mom yeah all right so
you're kind of running you're kind of
running the shot the spots in terms of
kids so growing up you're obviously out
and about you see you're getting into it
in high school
what is the daily like your stitch in
school because I I like to bring this
like ask these questions
because we could fast forward to 34 year
old you can go look yeah yeah I saw a
[__] billboard the other day
so it's a lot different so when that
first you starts out
you're obviously running around doing
some [__] you're but you're not smoking
what are you you're getting into the
your homies are associated what are you
doing are you getting fives you guys
want to parties [__] [__] up what is
bro literally everything okay so you're
those those groupings yeah just
literally selling [__] oh definitely
just bro like me I always was always
trying to find a new Hustle you know
what I mean just a new way like I used
to sell of course everybody sold candy
when I was in a middle school
I used to print out song lyrics and sell
those you know what I'm saying yeah 50
Cent at a Time lyrics song lyrics
and [__] and then I was on burning CDs
and
um from there like going to the
confidence Swap Meet the church the next
Hills I found out how to put like
applications on there and and uh games
and ringtones and just always just kept
upgrading the hustle and finding new
ways for me to make money so I was
always into that and then when I was
with the homies like yeah we you know
back then snatching people's phones and
it was all it was always Money Motivated
honestly
just actually on weed is kid no I tried
to sell cocaine for more crack for one
day who one day hold on you wake up go
you know what Zach I'm gonna go make
some money my homies on the corner so
they weren't telling it it wasn't even a
lot of it wasn't even like I don't think
that they was even making a lot of money
it was just like uh they're doing it so
my homeboy he was like I'm gonna give
you a rock man go go stand over there
and I was like all right
how are you
hell no I went on 13 and I probably was
like probably like 15.
enough to hold your own okay yeah old
enough but my homeboy as I was going
you know post up there's a lot of
smokers in the neighborhood
seen seen my homie get tackled boom
police was on him oh yeah so that was my
sign right there I was like this is a
sign
maybe if I would have made it one day or
the week I would have been like all
right yeah I'm saying but no I just
watched I watched that [__] and I was
like all right this ain't ain't worth it
that's a sign from God yeah truly to get
you the [__] out of there yeah that
doesn't happen but movies man God but
walks out Tech whoop door's not even
done closing I'm good yeah
cops in L.A tripping over weed back in
the 90s so much or not really
I mean I was a kid in the 90s so like
you're like what I can remember nah not
really because like if you have it in
the car they'll pull you over they'll
throw that [__] out of anything still
make you step on it yeah they wouldn't
they didn't really trip like that see
now I gotta now I gotta wrap my brain
differently because if you weren't the
drug kid as a kid and you're getting
into it you're just trying to make money
so you're doing your thing you guys are
stealing phones you're you're selling
would you say you're selling ringtone I
remember when that [__] was popping on
the next test oh yeah the chirps yeah
yeah all right 95s
that's what it was it was like a grayish
and it was blue but it was like to me
still to this day that was like one of
the hottest phones yeah I remember when
the first one again oh yeah the Flip's
gone damn and everybody had the black
the Blackberry was like oh you have a
business
yeah
the BBM yeah yeah what's that Blackberry
Messenger that's what it was called I
didn't have it I just knew the one kid
at school that had one and he had a pen
and he was a little [__] and he had
the pen no you can't understand the
wheel
I literally got one just to get on BBM
try to find women
well I don't even know what the age was
BBM out dude I don't even know what this
is so so you remember aim yeah it was
like hey but it was only for
blackberries damn they they were so it
was like the girls that felt like they
were more sophisticated got the black
bear they was like oh I'm not on AIM
that's ghetto we're on BBM so I'm like
[__] I need a Blackberry right now you
feel me hey what's up guys it's taking a
moment to talk about one of our longtime
sponsors and this is manscape go to
manscape.com forward slash Yola to get
20 off of anything and everything on the
site plus free shipping it's summertime
most of you are at the beach make sure
you're not looking gross and isn't gross
I mean make sure you don't have ball
hair spewing out of your shorts
manscape.com has everything you possibly
need to keep yourself groomed for both
heads in your life and for all the
Lumberjack dudes out there for your
beard the beard hedger from manscaped 20
different lengths for hair that way you
don't have a drawer full of attachments
and for all you guys that shave in the
shower it is 100 waterproof also for
manscape the beard shampoo and
conditioner dermatologist tested
formulation so you're not just putting
mystery goo on your face they got the
beard bomb the beard oil for all you
guys that shape your Captain Hook
mustaches and all that keep it fresh
keep it nice with manscaped once again
thank you so much to manscape for
sponsoring the show remember 20 off of
everything on the site and free shipping
all you gotta do is go to manscape.com
forward slash Yola or use Yola at
checkout 20 off plus free shipping and
it's getting better than that thank you
so much for manscape for sponsoring the
show back to the episode
so before we get into more ridiculous
things I want to talk about your podcast
and everything you got going on oh yeah
for a long time I just thought your name
was it sad on Instagram
no for real I was like no that's not bad
because people will walk up to me
they're like it's sad oh sad not just be
like yeah that's me what's up man I just
started owning it after a while No Lie
every time I see him like why does his
name set and then I met you go oh hey
who's got A.D something must be taken
across it's like
the guy has to be like a prince or
something like that
literally like
like
some Arab guy I don't know where the
[__] he's at but he on his page he has
like eagles on his arm and [__] like
that he looked like he's really living
life right I'm not gonna try to get it
from him yeah okay I think his money is
way longer than mine a lot of times it's
just some burner account that nobody's
better
this guy's got Eagles dude no he
literally has like the eagles are
selling it I'm like damn that's cool
like you deserve this one you gotta keep
it I'll be sad for a while and then I
was like
it's like man maybe I should make an
offer to get the A.D and I was like all
my handles are the same anyway and
people know me for that might as well
aren't changing now man it's like bro I
got Eagles you don't you can't pay me
yeah man keep it Eagle man yeah or at
least a forty thousand dollar Eagle yeah
so how did we get from hustle and the
blackberries up to YG game Trey Songz
um the biggest artist in the world man
just music in general so I used to uh
always go to like parties and [__]
so you know always like I said I was
always looking for women going with the
homies we going to parties and stuff
like that at the time Hollywood they
didn't really like
accept hip-hop like that so like all our
parties would be you know people throw
uh events in little Halls you know what
I'm saying and a lot of times like bad
[__] are happening there you know ain't
really no good security like that the
security may be somebody uncle or
something [__] always went left but um
like I said before music was always the
outlet
yeah
I gotta think for one Joe Moses I kind
of think OT Genesis as well too
um just being around them got me a lot
of my connections early on you know as
their music career grew
um I would meet like all the DJs I would
meet all the promoters I would meet all
the people and I didn't tell them that I
did music because I didn't want to step
on none of my homies toes and stuff too
so I was like okay eventually these
gonna be the same people that connect me
and connecting the Dotson yeah man just
building a relationship
um all throughout the club scene in La
man you meet all type of artists and
stuff you build your relationships and
um yeah I'm usually one of them guys
like once I [__] with you you know what
I mean I [__] with you for life for the
most part and like you know people like
Wiz man that's like one of my close
friends you know what I'm saying uh
Buster Rhymes and did a lot for us you
know I'm saying Trey Songz that's my
that's my guy you know what I mean but
OT Genesis that's my right hand man
um it's a lot of dope artists man
that's now out of all the legendary la
music that you grew up with we just had
Jeezy on here he was talking about Tupac
being his all-time favorite the Macarena
Thug Life album All That what's your top
three LA classic hip-hop album breakdown
look like
DJ Quick you got to put down in there
you know what I'm saying
um I don't know is it balancer options
or is it safe and sound regardless quick
goes on there for sure for sure
um I Gotta Give it to game too because
when I was coming up he was like the
only person that kept like put the West
on his back at the time so um I got to
put Chuck in there
um
documentary yeah that's probably one of
my all-time favorites that album changed
my life damn near made me want to make
music and move out to Cali the whole
[__] and the documentary uh two is the
first album that I I was ever featured
on as well too so shout out to Chuck
um yeah so quick game
oh man
I Gotta Give it to Ice Cube
hmm you know I mean what a hard question
Marty I know yeah
it's harder than yeah yeah what is the
average yeah yeah because it's like
legendary [__] yeah I can't wait come on
man
yeah and which I'm sure
death certificate is great
uh [__]
I'm gonna go death certificate
remember did you guys have media play
out here
the [__] is that it's like an FYE like a
Sam goody media player okay she said Sam
goody so he was one of those CD stores
yeah exactly going house out here
remember that yeah yeah I used to go lay
under Warehouse pretend like I was
reading the magazine undoing the CD
under the [__] bag
every [__] isn't that crazy
I know now kids just download this
Fool's risk it is freed not for real but
for dusters have a good thoughts but
just just imagine just imagine the
people that like really put all their
time into like I'm gonna get a record
store and like it's obsolete now oh God
if you can only survive as a record
store if you are you got everything yeah
you can't be a niche there's no punk
stores no more you can't go to a [__]
hip-hop store unless you're in a smaller
town that's like that's the spot
they moved but still they're still
selling man physical still selling but I
mean obviously it's not like it was it's
like a collectible story it's a
collector do they even like make them
like like new releases it depends we
just asked the Travis Thompson was on
your mic so what about records he goes
honestly
I'll make a certain amount and if if you
keep selling them we'll just make
another certain amount but we don't do
like a big batch like they used to which
is I [__] with the CD I buy CDs so
like I like to see the art I like the
artwork the booklet and it's from the
artist like this is what this fool was
like yo it's done
in the house go look exactly the albums
that I'm on like I I kept The copier too
just just yeah I mean show the kids one
day
on the wall yeah but damn sure but do
you see why physical is still sick and
that's what makes it it's way more
memorable
no I try to make beats before for like
a week
I got fruity loops and I was trying to
like do some [__] A Jackson 5 sample it
wasn't that bad maybe I should have kept
going with that but yeah I was like ah
so how did you start making music though
um literally having a Mickey Mouse mic
plugging that into it yes plugging that
into the computer and using um they
still got it it's called audacity
audacity doing that and um sound
recorder and just uploading that [__] to
Myspace
you in high school yeah what made you
want to do it though because there's got
to be a time like what [__] this Mickey
Mouse mic it's gonna work oh just just
music in general I used to I used to
just love listening to the radio West
Coast type of music and I you know start
writing Rhymes and I'm like man I can I
can do this yeah
what do you listen to I mean beside do
you listen to anything besides hip-hop
growing up
um moms have already playing r b uh
Casey and Joe Joe and Jaheim and you
know SWV and yeah acts like that all
right what no other [__] though that's
what that wasn't that it wasn't no rock
or none of that my mom's very diverse
but I grew up my West Coast [__] so Ice
Cube is but my mom bumped every morning
or ODB every morning just that's the
wake up that was the wake up every
morning my grandmother when she used to
wake up she's listening to Kiss FM so
I'll catch a Madonna sometimes oh okay
something like that
yeah yeah I grew up on some wild [__]
um so you're making music in high school
when do you realize that it's something
that's feasible because you know
everyone's like everyone wants to make
music when they're young
and then people realize like ah maybe
it's not for me when did you realize
like yo this is for me because if you're
starting high school and then after high
schools when you start really like this
is my [__] this is what I'm gonna be
doing and then obviously later on in the
years it's content but how do you
realize that this is more than just like
I'm gonna put all my time and energy
into it stay away from me I'm trying to
do some [__] I know I'm not trying to go
out and do that [__] right now well you
know like I said earlier I'm like I
wasn't a big Sports person yeah so I'm
like I ain't gonna make it out doing
sports I ain't gonna make it up it's
your vehicle yeah like and I I really
just fell in love with it like for reals
and I fell in love with battle rapping
so when I was in high school I was like
real big into like Dipset you know the
East Coast movement of what they was
doing because and I would just literally
just all day just think of bars and just
like right line right in line right in
line and when battle rap once I started
saying battle rap I was like oh that art
form is crazy still to this day like
King of the dark side all of that bro
smack everything just listening to that
and people just dissect you and just say
some crazy [__] and um daylight you know
you yeah I [__] with that for so heavy
they like ended my my battle rap video
he ended in person and oh my God it was
before or after it was that did you see
the new fight recently
no uh Spence and uh Crawford you didn't
see the boxing match no no I didn't okay
so it was uh Crawford went ham you know
what I'm saying that's how daylight did
to me bro you're like I think I can get
into this this fool just took a [__] on
stage damn it I'm out of here no I
literally like in high school would like
battle rap and all you know I was like I
was nice with the local kids and I'm
like all right
was this not like a van was this a full
Eight Mile movie no no no that would
have been way worse oh man that would
have been bad
um I ended up meeting this lady
me and my cousin we end up meeting this
lady and she's like oh I'm gonna bring
you to all these artists I manage and
stuff like that and she brings me in a
room with daylight and she's like oh you
know oh you can rap I'm like yeah and
I'm sitting there rapping that daylight
not knowing what's about to happen to
him
in this room and he said some of the
craziest [__] to you to me because
there's a fine line you can start
rapping for somebody and it's almost
like you're like rapping at them like
you're [__] like battle rapping them
and but it's different when you like I'm
nice yeah you feel me I can he's sitting
there all quiet waiting for you to stop
she walked me into a crime scene that's
exactly what happens
every line I'm like oh [__] I went home
and I was like I need to rethink the
battle rapping maybe I'll just be a dope
artist on songs you know what I'm saying
have bars on songs because what that
[__] just did ain't no coming back from
that yeah I love that shirt kind of died
with smack though so I mean in a lot of
ways yeah I guess that's poppers you
used to be like seven years ago I was
still remember I told you I was at a
booth and some guy came up to look at
some shirts in my clothing company when
we first started I'm like is that
disaster
shut up because I was so heavily into it
and it was but I was just hype like this
is I mean an athlete you know what this
fool could do it's battle rap it's
different dude it's not like listen to a
song wasn't it was like a Channel or
some [__] like a versus is now wasn't
there some like YouTube battle rap [__]
I don't know but I don't know no they
have caffeine they host battle raps on
the URL on here oh yeah yeah that's what
I'm thinking of the URL shut yeah I'm
not sure man I watched hours and hours
and hours of that [__] it's so cool you
can get lost in it yo definitely get
lost I like the ones where they end up
fighting like you know he wins if you
threw a punch he won you know that right
he's bird he burned you yeah murder move
Jay Mills all that [__] back in the days
like that's that and then both the
homies you know what I'm saying oh no
[__] yeah and just a bro really like the
process of what battle rappers have to
do
because I have a hard time remembering
anything
literally having a line after line and
having to stop and deliver that in Step
man that [__] that [__] is not easy to
do no it's poetry with [__] talking and
it Rhymes heavily and the ship might
spiral into a [__] brawler
hey man you got me thinking like I've
been it's been too long since I watched
some Battle Raps you ever seen it live
no
does that shout out to disaster uh
disaster invited me to one of his
battles and he was battling a little
person
no that's not fair it was that's not
fair because you know he did this eight
times
come on
short joke you can think of that did he
burn disaster at all it was like me with
daylight oh
yeah short people got you gotta have
some ammunition [__] ready two disasters
he oh man it's like watching a boxing
match yeah I think that's why I think he
said everybody in him is still on the
height is still in school going oh we're
all in the hallway still we're just
grown up that's right when you stop in
public when you see a fight what do you
do you don't go you guys should stop
no matter how old you are no you just
need to mind your business that's why
I'm still somebody to turn around on you
I still look though
I'm like world star you know man that's
what I'm saying they're like oh [__]
oh [__] everyone's gonna
do care if you're 60.
it's the dude that tries to break it up
that always gets [__] shot I know
it's so sad that is think about that
every time that's ever happened but if
it's getting bad I gotta I gotta do
something like yo can you guys please
stop
you won
you you know what I'm saying bro it's
been a long time since I've seen some
people fight in public damn it's been a
minute man like a long time I don't go
to clubs I don't go to bars I don't go
anywhere but you know it's crazy just
driving through L.A you'll randomly see
people punching each other oh yeah I see
my homeless people [__] fighting yeah
they'd be like yeah they're talking
about like a fight like a fight between
agile people under like 30. it's been a
minute that's drunk downtown Buffalo
culture all day yeah see I don't go to
bars and [__] too many people just have
too many things going on in their lives
and they all come out to drink at the
same time it's like bro something's
gonna happen you realize that right
they put a bunch of little kids in
timeout in the same room something's
gonna happen was that uh was the
homeless situation in L.A as crazy as it
is when you're growing up as it is now
hell no not even close nah like you
didn't you didn't I mean of course a
skill roll you know I think that's
always been skit roll but for the most
part that's like where you would see an
abundance of homeless people and it's
crazy too because they I just read that
like they've gave billions of dollars of
trying to clean the streets up and it's
like they can't do it that's right I saw
that and even too I heard that like um I
don't know how true it is but I think
this week they're bringing like 2 000
um homeless people from Alaska to Los
Angeles so I'm like y'all bringing
people in like what the [__] is going on
should be the opposite Alaska's got
hella free space that's what I'm saying
we get paid to live there yeah
what the hell's going on hey man they're
trying to make it you're you remember
Demolition Man yeah yeah I'll get the
first customer know what I'm talking
about that's how I feel they're trying
to do the Earth like nah graffiti gets
covered up quick live underground if
you're gonna be homeless feel like
they're trying to like bring him in so
everybody gets so fed up like no no
we're gonna have to have a section for
these people because you know I was have
you been to San Francisco recently no no
not in a while it's bad in San Francisco
it's worse in here
wow it's bad and the living out there is
worse than out here it's uh it's as far
as like that there's written stuff oh
yeah it's the most expensive place
besides New York I think it's got a
Silicon Valley
I don't know probably all the tech
companies and stuff out there but but
it's like going to Skid Row but like yo
you know it's getting wrong spring and
like seventh-ish it gets shitty like
that one wild cornerfuls are watching TV
right there on the corner you know what
I'm talking about I still live downtown
so like all these sections like also for
the TV that has like a theater outside
anyway and then there's that you know
that one store I think it's with an
apple on it and it's you know what I'm
talking about of course man
it looked like that San Francisco but I
was downtown just in front of like
businesses nothing was open it looked
like [__] hadn't been opened in a while
it looked like it Demolition Man when
they go underground that's sad yeah it
was some wild [__] but I think it's
getting worse man I think I didn't think
it is getting worse and you're saying
they're shipping in more people
even like say is like uh the last I
think today is the last day that the
rent assistance was out for Kobe so all
the people who didn't like pay their
rent during covet
today's like the last no like you have
to pay everything like it's due
yeah no one's able to pay that no it's a
lot of consequences I think it's gonna
be like Mass evictions out here a lot
not just out here but just like all the
United States
[__] up man
I don't know anything about that I
didn't know that yeah I didn't know that
at all damn
well we just got some [__] on the show
all right yes it always shocks me like
you're going on Orange County where I
live you won't see one thing yes you
will I mean in certain spots so
Fullerton and Fullerton a little bit but
he loses South past that it's like they
have it figured out it's not working it
is it is different but I heard in Orange
County they let them be on the beach
damn oh yeah I've never seen that yeah
that's how it doesn't seem where you
live as well San Diego is like so clean
bro I'm trying to bring my kids down
here you guys like for real like yeah I
haven't I don't do [__] I don't go
anywhere so I don't know shout out to
San Diego man San Diego they don't [__]
with the wind is heavy down here you
still control for hash out there what do
you mean
well we got like a [__] felony for
bringing it has hash out there like four
years ago and it's I don't know now
everybody's blowing I know the weed's
fine I'm saying like they treat
concentrates like it's still 2016. I
could be wrong don't hold me to it but
this was three four years ago wow yeah
yeah I don't know I don't know but uh
back to early ready circled all the way
back okay
like I said earlier before we get onto
some ridiculous talk
the podcast your guys's show everything
you're doing we went like that and I
said it's sad and then we went and went
left
oh no I was like we're here now it's
like Plinko that's our conversations
remember like Price is Right yeah
exactly drop the coin that's us yeah
we're trying to get to that point but we
might hit all these on the way down yeah
because
I'm really into podcasting as far as all
the behind the scenes [__]
and you obviously just stepped out on
your own
as and just said well [__] I'm gonna do
my own [__] and
are innovating now you guys are booking
live shows you got your own [__] going
so for everyone out there what's like
where can they find you feed me on the
world man shout out to the team what's
your advice to anybody starting to
stream starting their own podcast
wanting to start their own YouTube like
what have you learned doing it on your
own
um honestly you got a fun you gotta fun
you know yourself don't be a uh don't be
cheap with it that extra camera the
extra lens that every little thing that
you think that you need you need it yeah
yeah I mean because you're going up
against millions of people literally
um having the right thumbnails to me is
like super important
oh man shout out to all
uh thumb cuts out to our guy yeah man um
making sure make sure your your titles
are correctly because you can the way
that is written is going to determine
how a video is gonna perform or not 100
and I'll give y'all a free tip you can
go to uh chat GTP oh yeah and ask it
that too and you can get some uh titles
yeah too yeah they know yeah but no but
also learning the technical side of
everything that's what I like
and I like that I can teach that to
other people too yeah of course so like
even just I'm like if I didn't do what I
did I was like what the [__] is this but
I know how to work the road Caster now
and I can hook up the mics and put this
off yeah yeah yeah we try to preach that
all those skills are like what really
matters in in this day and age to being
able to like not only for yourself but
then to add value to other people
so now that you uh I'm sure everybody
who knows what we're talking about you
used to work for no jumper you'd be on
that show and then you left obviously
and then we've had duno on here so my
brother do know yeah I just recently
went on his show I got that man so high
and he didn't smoke weed he no he don't
he didn't know he didn't rushed my weed
so [__] up it was amazing to see it I
gotta be honest he's he's one of the
funniest fools ever so you were on no
jump rate you left in the whole
controversy thing that went down you
guys left now you started your own [__]
you guys are doing your own thing fig
Community which you're gonna have a live
show which I saw the billboard
billboard I I don't know who I was
talking like billboard Dale so you guys
do it at the novo when is that that's
November 18th oh you guys have time yeah
so we doing that we're doing the um
Gramercy theater in um and then we're
doing uh I forgot the venue in San
Francisco so those are the names yeah
uh Cobbs San Francisco
I'm not sure but no [__] one of the
other shows what are the dates those um
November 16th
November 15th no November 16th November
15th the 16th and the 18th
and these are the first live shows these
no this would be the second live show so
we did the El Rey and we ended up
selling it out in 24 hours so they end
up adding another day and we sold that
out as well too
wow awesome and stepping on your own
like you always forbidden Waters almost
like it's all familiar territory and
then you guys sold out two nights I just
wanted to flip the table when he said
that I didn't even know that that's like
once you do those shows that was
um
well last month oh yeah and what was the
format of the live show if you want to
talk man it was dope man it was super
dope shout out to pawn shout out to T
rail shout out to will
um
for one t real he had a vision of like
we gotta have the best this and we got
to have that so you know shout out to
our sponsors we got the screen and in
the screen it had like the uh a house
that's on Figueroa Street like where T
rails from and you know the props on the
stage we had like low rider bikes we had
couches we had all these different props
to try to give it like an authentic uh
La look yeah and you know just having
the rundown of the show and just
everybody coming out and us bringing all
our shows together and doing everything
man the people was dope meet and greets
merged the whole nine yards amazing
feeling how long was the show oh I think
I think that's about we're like all
right it's been two hours it's like
being at a movie I've gotten everything
I could possibly probably get at unless
we're just like let's get let's take
some shot
that it's more like yo we're having a
party now that's the meet and greet
afterwards yeah exactly like that right
afterwards well like the last one we did
our meet and greet started before the
show oh [__] yeah oh man that's got to
be a little like uh to me to me it makes
it better though yeah yeah because if
people like they get to meet you for the
first time and you know you showing them
love and they are uncomfortable cool
cool cool and they go watch the show
they probably like I really [__] with
them more
you're not wrong versus you know you do
the show you might be exhausted and
tired you may not want to take a picture
of somebody you may not want to do that
too so okay that's a fair point first
impression my thing would have been like
I don't want to get tired of the meet
and greet and then go on and show and do
a bad job but you're right you're gonna
be so hyped up to go do this show why
the [__] wouldn't you just make sense
okay that makes sense so you guys can do
three shows in uh November in November
you guys have a lot of time and you sold
your other ones out in 24 hours this
one's gonna sell out come on when do the
tickets go like available no they're
available right now oh okay you're good
we good you're super good are you gonna
come out open up with like five ten
minutes we're gonna have fun I'm saying
with some music with some music yeah to
me that's like it's kind of kind of
weird all right is it yeah because
you're separating because I tried what
are you doing I try to separate it
like you don't want you don't want to
just oh be out there all day and then
special guests performing myself
all right that's cool all right I get
you I get that but Marty I also
understand what you're saying kind of
like the Chappelle you want to maximize
everything yeah yeah I could just like
if we were to do a live show and you
were doing comedy like I've worked with
shows that do that like they'll do a
live podcast but they open up with 15
minutes comedy type [__] oh yeah he does
all the comedians though that's their
[__]
like what is wrong with you you know
what I mean funny you saying that dude
no it makes perfect sense
oh man thank you for having another show
when I was a kid it starts rapping
all right man I gotta go you're right
all right I understand I get it from
your point
oh my God all right so how can everybody
get tickets
um go to our Instagram or any of us me
Tyrrell Pawn
um smack duno Heather the whole Squad
man fake Muny World Community back on
fig it's in everybody's a bio nice man
was it was it like hell putting together
these events would you say or was it
relatively pretty easy to book your own
[__] shout out to will
um yeah he handled all of that oh okay
nice yeah they have the people doing
that [__] too but I know it took like
months of preparation of like getting
everything together and stuff too so
when it comes to our business man we're
100 serious and we're not trying to cut
no corners we're not trying to go the
cheap route we want the best product for
the people you know when the experience
this stuff was yeah the best advice I
got when I got into videography was
exactly what you said like just buy what
you need yeah buy it because I would
have spent a couple years bullshitting
my way up to what I needed and it I
would have missed out on a ton of
opportunities with my [__] rinky dick
[__] the meantime for sure yep
so how long are you doing the show now
what's what's yes it's about almost a
year right it's been
March April July it's been like six
months foreign
why does it feel like it's been long ago
it do like feel like it's longer and
time is flying definitely
so yeah it's been like like five six
months
damn I pray my time so would you say is
that a situation that like you'll look
back on and be like I was really like
frustrated at first but it turned out to
completely be the blessing that needed
to happen yeah I mean I feel like even
before you know we made the move and
deal we did we were like okay if we're
gonna do this we're gonna do it the
right way and make sure that we were
straight and stuff like that and it's
still a learning process but it's you
know it's better to to build something
that is your own you know I mean that's
your baby 100
um and learn and bump your head along
the way with it of course then
everything is invested and it's you
you're not like we always say it's like
almost like a sponsorship when it's not
yours it's your own sponsorship I'm
saying when it's not yours it's like all
right you sponsor me I have no skin in
this that's it once if the sponsorship
ends them out
so if you make your own [__] yeah like
you're saying you're doing your own
thing it's yours you have your own your
own Billboards you're not how much we
get of our priorities and like no it's
us we split what we get and even even
with that it's more like we're like okay
let's not be dumb let's build let's put
the money back into what we're doing so
as much as we shoot let's put that back
into that let's upgrade the equipment
let's find out you know what's new
things that we can do before we even sit
there and say oh let's add this to our
pockets yeah smart you guys are growing
[__] he's a master at that I grew up
four businesses this past [__] years
five I've been doing a bunch of [__]
um
so when it comes to the show to
podcasting is there any other shows
you're watching because I know Marty
watches shows we do a podcast I do
YouTube I don't watch anything I don't
watch other YouTubers I don't watch
podcasts okay I would say this like
actively at least
the goats like galy and wallow like I
catch their interviews
um I like a lot of say cheese
um
drink Champs too Joe Budden but you know
academics when it comes down to
streaming ain't nobody [__] with him
when they come down to stream oh you do
you watch streaming too
now I'll watch academics because you
know he's for somebody to do that do
that by themselves that's very
entertaining you got to be very
entertaining to six seven eight hours
and you're by yourself Talking damn yeah
so I don't know I don't want to watch
this [__] when you're doing streams are
you doing podcasts like you literally
have other people to bounce ideas off in
conversation and when it's yourself
that's also takes a a good skill but
yeah but on YouTube man I'll be watching
the most random [__] bro
you get like in a dark hole yes you're
not watching active people like that guy
I watched this girl I just name the
people that I do watch but that's it I'm
saying besides on YouTube like I just
watch compilations I don't want I watch
wild weird [__] on YouTube right there's
no YouTubers I'm like yo I love this
person for this and this and this I
don't do that Cal Huff's videos what's
that when they're like cutting the cows
oh my god oh no and I like to watch the
people that that come and help the
horses oh and they clean it up oh you're
talking about when they shave it yeah I
thought you meant like some
slaughterhouse [__] for a minute
cutting off their hooves
I thought dude no no yeah yeah I've seen
the horse ones that [__] so dope to
watch and you can see the horse go hey
[__] thank you you can see it on
their face like
what is it they sigh and [__] it's like
when uh cows or horses hooves get really
infected right yeah and the guy will
come up
they shave it up they clean it it's just
insane that [__] that people think like
why is my horse dying like let's fix
this yeah no it's it's crazy and also
like uh people that be like cleaning
carpets oh you watch all that long form
Tick Tock [__] basically it's this dark
and it's like yo it was a tie-dye rug I
cleaned it with nine other guy too he'd
just be drinking like he'd be chugging
sodas and [__] the big giant yeah
but
don't let nobody look up no [__] on
yours because it'll [__] up your
algorithm
my daughter my little brother yeah my
daughter memes take me no mines is not
memes it's just Roblox
[Music]
five Roblox videos and [__] and I'll be
like [__] I'm missing all the good
videos I don't use a search bar do you
use a search bar I don't put goofy
satisfied
I don't I just click some shingles
suggested all right let's go let's go
down like like a rabbit hole damn you
guys really use the app like you're
supposed to no I use the t i watch it on
my TV though oh yeah they're same same
[__] it's hard to like click the [__]
the next videos and [__] that's why like
all you're saying no like it just keeps
going you just let it you know I don't
play I'll be watching some stupid [__]
and then I'm just watching world's
dumbest [__] cop interactions like
why am I watching 1997 episode cops
right now but that [__] tight no that's
just no dope there's certain [__] that's
Timeless you logged in the podcast
account you're like why is there all
children's videos yeah I did I was like
why is this a bunch of kids I'm like oh
I mean his daughter must Got a Hold like
why are we following a bunch of kids
shows I even said that the other day
like this is weird Marty why are you oh
the baby the ruins your goddamn account
you're never getting those suggestions
back you dude just gotta like hey stay
off of it yeah wipe it my own brother
Rocco dank memes oh my God was [__]
people screaming and Eight Second clips
of stupid [__] like oh man and ruined my
whole day
Jesus Christ
um ready top three my favorite movies of
all time Catch Me If You Can Wait with
Leonardo DiCaprio damn you're the second
guest to mention that that's the number
who was the other guest that said that I
don't remember I do kind of remember
that
where he's uh he plays a a con artist
yeah yeah yeah I saw that in a hotel a
couple months ago [__] it was fire and
he catches his ass at the end or true
story I didn't see the very end it's not
where he caught him and he's on the
plane he ends up like working for the
FBI afterwards that's what and it just
shows on a black screen it says the
words of what happened I did see the end
then damn Catch Me If You Can Tom Hanks
at home
damn it's a classic it's a great movie
damn top three okay
oh let me see
don't be a menace to Drinking Your Juice
I mean don't be missing South Central
While Drinking Your Juice in the Hood I
got to be number two likes to watch that
[__] I'm pregnant how do you know I have
11 kids come on what's your name again
cigarette
that's true I meant that's why every
time you say that Marty and you guys
don't ask me we have a problem that's
why you say that what's your name again
cigarettes that's whatever for me that's
a classic man if I had to give it a
third
loves that [__] cause I'm thinking of
the movies that I like repeatedly
watched okay you know what I mean did
y'all see some good movies recently
recently no I went to the movie guy oh
yeah yeah but I watched a lot of bad
movies in the past couple like weeks
it's the last movie you said I watched
that movie asteroid City in the in the
theater what the [__] is asteroid City
that don't even sound like some [__]
I'll go see I didn't like it I just seen
Oppenheimer yo is it tight it was a it
depends what you it depends on like what
type of film you like I like all movies
was it well made oh amazingly man what's
the acting on point acting was and was
the purpose of the story sick loved it
then there's a good movie but I know
some people like there ain't no action
in there I'm like no oh that's true are
you watching glorious bastards of course
all right that there's a scene in there
that's a 25 minute dialogue scene I was
like this the whole time like what the
[__] they're just talking that's a good
movie to me but some people like that's
just boring yeah people like I just like
good movies all right damn okay so it's
amazing man if you don't if you want
good movies Robert Downey Jr man he
killed him
yes I know nothing about it except that
Gillian Murphy or Killian Murphy dude
it's about the atomic bomb or yeah
damn I I have my nephews I wouldn't
watch damn Elementals
the [__] is that the little kids movie
My Little My nephew oh the Pixar [__]
whack ass movies that was what come on
man I want some pics I wanted some more
[__] that was the most depressing boring
ass little kid movie
man so I've been watching nothing all
right I'm about to watch Ace Ventura
again classic all right I'm about to
watch that all right David 390s movies
growing up as a kid damn see that we
gotta spread it out because you said
Catch Me If You Can three three ninjas
three ninjas Tommy
Tom
[Applause]
Tom's name yeah that got to be that the
the original Ninja Turtles movie yeah
that was classic and then on YouTube
there was a guy he made him called [__]
turtles yeah
that's on e-bombs world remember that
that's when that [__] got popular
no number two that is a ghetto Elmo
remember that [__] oh man or The
Psychotic where he has the knife in the
peephole yo that shit's funny Kermit
the Kermit the classic one
there they had they had the Barney [__]
on there too I remember the Barney yeah
it was all type of [__]
um let me see the Ninja Turtles and then
uh
you know what it got to be
I want to say Menace to Society oh
that's a Saturday
yeah damn
but that's like iconic classic yeah
growing up as a kid so technically
that's your favorite like La 90s Hood
movie then yeah Miss a society
what's better than that
nothing I mean I always love boys in the
hood growing that's right to me that's
number two kid I mean I love it of
course
but that's even South Central the
movie's pretty good too oh great movie I
just remember when Ice Cube's walking
away and I'm like my mom's like look he
disappeared I remember asking my mom
like why you disappear and then because
I was a kid I'm like
because when I was a kid don't you
remember like
he's really dead remember that when you
thought of that as a kid like that guy's
really dead
and then she's like let's see that
Friday
it didn't click as a kid Willy Wonka was
a real person to me as a kid you know
what I'm saying like everyone was a real
guy that was still alive doing that she
wanted to go to the Chocolate Factory
hell no I saw what happened to that fact
this is basically suffocated in a tube
man like I'm good everything worked out
my kids got [__] up all of them yeah
except for the poor kid with the shitty
parents it's kind of like a house of
horrors type show it was okay yeah
a little Sinister throw some more music
I mean look at the the tunnel scene all
right [__] scared the [__] out of me as
a kid remember that
I should
where do we stand on Pee-wee Herman all
right PeeWee Herman just I was literally
just talking about this yesterday and I
said rip and then they were like no
don't say rip that's what they said to
me and it was like I was like all right
[__] them then they're like they're like
no he uh
it's a lie and I'm like okay RP again
they're like no look at this
look at this okay I don't know what to
say
usually if you got a customer guy that
much it's not good yeah it's a toss-up
we didn't talk about this last night I
never saw anything about him being
a weirdo with kids I never saw that and
if there is out there I'll see and like
Dan that said but I read that he like
turned himself in
no because when I was a kid my aunt
pepper had a shirt that had a picture of
PeeWee Herman and under it said
masturbate and it was a big that was
only the thing him beating off in the
morning when he got got beat off in a
movie theater around a bunch of dudes in
a porn movie theater
so like he was doing what every other
man in the road was doing I get it he
was being weird he was PeeWee but he's
Pee-wee Herman so like oh yeah you can't
be Peewee you can't be Pee-wee Herman in
here yeah put a hood on and you talk to
couches and [__] man
on the couch
yeah bro it was weird anyway I post that
[__] too hell no I don't know I grew up
on that fool I if it is we it's true
about that that's sad I never knew about
that but I remember him beating off when
I was a kid it's like well I mean he's a
guy like
he's not just Pee-wee Herman that's why
I remember like he's he's probably a
different guy outside of Pee-wee Herman
I don't care what year it is though
going to a theater and beating off of
the room full of people's insane yo it
was a porn theme
that's what they used to do it's a porn
theater that's our dude used to go to
hook up with each other hey what's up
hey what's up dude like oh like that was
the thing it's like a it's like okay
yeah yeah naked it's not a regular
[__] Regal no no no
there's no Jujubes in [__] Sour Patch
Kids mixed in with dicks
it's straight you got water and blue
dick that's about it
I like how we got in this conversation
all right I like that we want some
people hear him into this yeah yeah
right keeping his memory alive and
clearing the air here we don't know if
we need to keep his memory alive oh man
Paul Reuben let's just think of him as a
pen blow Derek for real he's Derek
foreign
crushed it he is a little [__] though
he turned him in at the end anyway we'll
move on with that love people Airman
that was a great movie [__] that dude
they hold up the People Herman's biggest
version big adventure remember that
movie all that [__] yo no the movie the
movie's great it goes to [__] I
remember the movie oh that's a good ass
movie I ain't gonna lie man he was cool
back then
come on man that's a great movie at the
end he goes and [__] steals him from
Hollywood he gets his bike back what a
good [__] movie
hey man I don't think I ever saw it Oh
go watch it with your kid you got
children I don't know if that's one of
these dudes my kids shouldn't be
watching just oh no he talking to like
all of his his appliances and [__]
they got mouths and eyes and [__] but in
people's big adventure it's not he's
never he's just no no he was big
adventure is different it's a wage I
didn't really watch the show as much I
didn't like it that much like you're
gonna sit on the couch that got eyes and
stuff yeah and it's called toilets got
up yeah that's kind of trippy [__] A lot
of that like remember the special word
of the day and I would go wow but I was
a kid I was like [__] three huh
all right all right we'll just say that
that's sad maybe not Paul Rubens if he's
a jerk yeah or a creep but Pee-wee
Herman the character that's sad he's
gone damn Marty
what happened sometimes this happens you
know and everything in between like I
said in the intro yeah this is pretty
much like on your guys's show I'm sure
with four people
and sometimes more
it goes off all the time
do you have a reoccurring segment of
when you guys forget [__]
bro I just be hoping like somebody pick
it up oh like that I can't see I got you
nah dude here it's almost like yo we
gotta stop when it's just sometimes it's
me and him it's been three hours you
should probably start talking about
random [__] but it's I mean it's going
down the rabbit hold up yeah it's fun
it's garage time are you in dude I'm
Gonna Keep Your Food Series going nice
that's like yeah the next one come on
next week oh yeah so we got about uh
four episodes three episodes done on our
new channel what's been your favorite
one so far
um vodka Burger man yeah vodka no vodka
Burger where's that at it's in um damn
kind of like the Echo Park area
got you yeah man this the chef over
there he had these like a Lotte fries
crazy they're not even like a Lotte
fries they're like
[__] animal style fries but it has
um what's that cheese on there the
Escada I can't say that [__] yeah
whatever whatever cheese [__] with an
accident and a c yeah
I don't know
yo um
a food Siri because look at do you would
you guys get messed with on on YouTube
like here's your uh do they restrict
your [__] the food no no YouTube oh yeah
oh so you guys feel that too yeah it all
depends well I know like I know like you
smoking weed they from shopping tripping
on that [__] any episode do they all get
restricted I think after like the first
five six minutes it's weird though cause
you can upload something that is like
family friendly and you'll get a yellow
one you'll be like what the [__] is what
is it okay so you don't get it either it
doesn't make sense right you're talking
about like the real restricted though no
I don't get those uh okay only like the
only time you get those is like when
when you make like a
copyright strike somebody's song or
something like that oh okay so you get
do you get age restrictions on your
videos sometimes okay you have to be
doing some [__] to get ages yeah okay
but that's very like wait until you got
to sign in to view the content yeah and
[__] like that that [__] up a lot of
you yeah it's all all of our episodes
okay so basically it's just that smarty
we're doing a poll because nah we're
doing a poll YouTube's [__] with a
lot of content creators we're noticing a
lot of people been on I've been noticing
even like we're saying Dr Drew on his
Instagram you know
a lot of different people you wouldn't
even think about but it used to because
it used to seem like it was such like a
I mean for a while it was like a
reliable way like almost like a job like
I can really count on this this is we
get an average amount every month but
ever since they switched out CEOs and
[__] that should have been real wonky
before I mean us obviously we're pushing
it because we got the weed and yeah
this is really frustrating you know and
it's like super inconsistent and then
you look and they suggest you these
crazy ass prison videos that aren't age
restricted or some super gangster rap
wild [__] and it's like cool this should
just be a place where adults can just
post regular their [__] and when you log
into YouTube is your first short just
like a gun with an extended clip
let me see
every time I log in like bro 9.6
suggested me crazy gunshin like restrict
the G they restricted our gz episode
eight or straight today yeah something
we didn't even smoke it was basically a
TED Talk he came on here and talked
about entrepreneurs yeah you see the
shorts just I I don't know right when I
get on it's always just okay yeah
dude they're not gonna get onto shorts
and just search everything rotating
oh [__] that just tripping out right now
YouTube just starts talking [__] back to
us and [__] yeah it's all good it's all
good you guys are on Spotify and all
other things right so can you it's just
fig Community big Mutiny world world
makes the world
then what's the difference with like the
the community community is mine back on
fig is a t rails yeah and do those world
is Doodles so we just combined all three
how long you guys been knowing each
other for
not long oh okay yeah really yeah I mean
I knew Tyrell a tiny bit longer than you
guys met when you were over there no
jumper are you serious yeah oh yeah hit
it off yeah not too real but do you know
for sure so you guys just hit it I guess
you just [__] with each other that's
what that is first day the first day I
filmed with doing I was like I like him
[Music]
you'd be in any situation and the fact
that you don't smoke weed at all
that's good that's a rare you're a good
that's a you know we all have that one
home is around a bunch of like you're in
the biggest other Stoner fools of like
you're around so much fire you don't
even touch but I don't like weed same
with me like I always drink [__] like I
don't drink that much I got [__] to do I
can smoke weed all day and then get my
[__] that I can't drive across town like
yo I had 30 shots yeah I can do that I
can and the weed is the opposite that's
crazy I couldn't even imagine like
I couldn't I can't wrap my head around
that but I didn't get [__] up when we
drank though that's fun it's a point
yeah I mean like I I just it's like with
we like I can smoke a lot of weed but
I'm sure you're big can you drink a
fifth and be okay yeah same I don't even
drink that much I'm like I can chug a
fifth and be
Hennessy
Hennessy I usually start getting sick
off it though it's like kind of sugary
it's more like syrupy yeah I started
feeling like the yeah am I like stomach
remember how much I was drinking I
didn't see back then [__] welcome to
Tequila why I only drink the uh Azul one
that shit's bomba come on what the thing
yeah just like at bars but how much do
you want for this year oh yeah they're
gonna text you no more it's like twice
maybe three times as much as the bars
what made you choose that brand and they
make you like it so much I like the bill
no it wasn't John's wedding and I know
if John's drinking something like all
right what is it then bougie [__] I
have a homie that just uh you know when
she's like you rich guy what are you
what is this what's this new thing here
it must be [__] it must be ridiculous
let me see what it is all right you're
right you know what I mean he's super
anal about all that [__] so my God let
me try this drink it's a bell all right
I [__] with it I was like oh this is
tight yeah we got some over there
actually it's been there for [__]
months barely drink that [__]
um where can everybody find your
Instagrams
um it's Instagram and socials social
sphere Community world yeah just uh
follow the page
um Community Clips as well back on fig
duno's World Ace boy everybody man it's
a whole bunch of the stuff so on
Instagram it's literally big Community
world no your personal oh it's A.D or
it's sad it looks like you know what
you're saying all right so
um on do you have Twitter all that stuff
now
just not Twitter no more I gotta be
honest I know it changed and I still
looking for the bird me too of course I
know where my app is I know it's there
and I still go
did y'all get on threads as soon as they
uh I only did so I thought it was
another app so people wouldn't steal my
because I get a lot of fake accounts as
me and they try sell packs damn and
that's why I'm like I locked down
everything on everything because people
are like
yo you got 3 000 followers on this new
album bro it's not me
and it was already reserved for you and
people know people take it and they're
just selling packs here's my telegram
here's my telegram you know
there's thousands of them
but on threads it's just hooked to your
Instagram yep I had no idea I made this
app I caught on there fast I was like
it's looked to my [__] no one can steal
it yeah I don't [__] with that app do
you like it I mean I feel like two or
three days the hype was there yeah and
it was turned off once I realized that
you're deleting your Instagram account
by doing the [__] threads there's no
[__] porn on here I feel like that
was a deal breaker for a lot of people
because Twitter is great Twitter
remember the the Chappelle skit where
he's like I'm walking into the internet
yeah yeah that is Twitter
do you think he realized he was like now
X is x videos if you post a video it's
no longer a tweet it's a [__] x video
the biggest [__] porn site in the
world oh do you think he realized all
their market research and they didn't
[__] I saw the trending on Twitter
we saw a training on its own apps
talking about how it's [__] up that's
crazy
what do you call the Post now besides
that like
tweet was such a great word it's like
but it still says tweet it's not called
Twitter they're gonna definitely take
that out yeah then what is it I think
they changed they changed the words it's
gonna be x.com it's not called.com right
now
it's not called Twitter No Twitter's
gone I thought it was just changing the
logo no I don't like it it's x.com I
don't like it that's dumb bad move
because I think what you're going to see
blue happen is it's gonna become Uber
GrubHub Twitter X is going to be all
these different apps in one that's what
he said he's trying to do I don't like
that I damn that means someone could
come up and make a new Twitter
where is it out there
and look what happened it sucks but it's
hooked to your Instagram
You Gotta Go uncensored you got to be
able to sell like not sell show packs
only fans [__] gotta be able to go
this is where I live because I can show
whatever I want here that's what needs
that's what makes the world benefit from
Twitter where you go to [__] Vegas go
to strip clubs try to make money drink
gamble or smoke [__] weed
that's what your internet should be
whatever you want it to work that's the
new Twitter needs to be all right just
take all the scammers off we're done
we're good
yeah we're gonna keep going about random
ships
sorry sorry all right here we go thank
you so much man thank you for being here
Marty got anything else you want to talk
about thank you sir I know the fans have
been asking for this one for a long time
I appreciate y'all having me man yeah we
try to just ask questions that people
you know I like it though it's different
it's different right there's a lot of
people are congrats chill out in here
yeah like we're hanging out oh I gotta
add another 90s movie in here goofy
movie
um
pizza every time my little fat ass kid
as a kid I thought of Goofy Movie Pizza
I thought of All Dogs Go to Heaven Pizza
remember that another classic
I was a little fat kid so I was always
looking at [__] like crazy looking at
cartoon pizza and getting hungry yeah
old I was a [__] starving ass little
boy and then I got became a fat kid but
dude me too bro bro it happens it
happened and then I saw a Home Alone 2
when you have a pizza getting a limo for
yourself
[__] the ice cream [__] the [__] toys
let me get that New York pizza that's
how I feel yeah damn I'm [__] hungry
apparently
but for real though All Dogs Go to
Heaven Pizza is the best cartoon Pizza I
ever seen in my damn life
up on the screen and that's how we end
the show we talk about the Goofy movie
All Dogs Go to Heaven ranting high as
hell you got me on good you could take
that one with that's just fine
shout out to the guy I think Where I
Leave Big Chief man I got it like I said
when you walked in I didn't know that
you were part of that that's awesome so
where's your what's your strain called
oh it was a marquee stream Uzumaki yep
you you name that yeah with the cross
Naruto I don't watch animes
is that why it's my favorite is it one
with the little cloud is that the logo
is that that's Dragon Ball Z no no
the little logo that everyone's wearing
is that a cloud it's like a little Puff
of smoke or clap
well brand new it's brand new I've seen
hella fools with it take a little symbol
some people wear like a little bandana
with it and a little metal plate yeah
that's Naruto
is it not a club like a it's like I
don't know I thought it was a cloud no
it's not a cloud I thought it was a
[__] Cloud man cause I know what
Dragon Ball Z is that's why I'm like nah
that's not Dragon Ball but Goku was on
the little [__] Cloud yeah no there's
no person I know Dragon Ball Z I know
all that [__] but I didn't know about
this new [__] yeah yeah I don't watch
animes I need to get on I watch Acura is
that what it's called Acura I don't know
what that is Dash It's hard that's a
Japanese one from like the early 2000s
that shit's sick it's a movie I gotta
[__] with it format or metal full metal
heavy metal remember Heavy Metal the uh
old anime well it's kind of anime but
it's a crazy cartoon from the 90s or 80s
watch that [__] I already watched that
it's gory as [__] I don't know about the
show I don't know I don't want your
animations
I'm lost that's what happens with the
weed man damn oh yeah uzumak you called
it that you know the cross of it it's uh
they always switch it
but the new version right now because we
have two different versions oh it's
crazy it's like a purple is it an OG is
it a sativa is it like a Jack it's what
would you consider what's it look like
I'm really lost right now
this looks like weed and [__]
see this is why
it was hilarious it sounds like a weapon
or like a bomb is it green or purple no
it's
uh
oh man
it's colorful can I say there there
that's all I do is no it's definitely on
the more light purple rinse look inside
but it's great though all right there we
go
this is a guy that does detailed weed
descriptions
all right and you sell it through Big
Chief yeah which is on the legal market
right yep okay where can you where can
you refine that everywhere you can go to
the Cure company oh you can go that's
where I'm going right now yeah man shout
out to my guy Mike over there
um you can go to any damn near cookie
store
um okay so it's just it's spread her out
yeah spread out okay so wherever Big
Chief is held here and that's the
flower's not there that I have the card
oh yeah cards too yeah it's live like
live resume yep all right good [__] yeah
dude oh it's a legal Market yeah good
[__] for you yeah my homie runs dtpg
which is cure company all right yeah I'm
gonna go CLG right now nice yeah good
man that's that's one of the biggest
shops in La yeah one of the best spots
to be in Santa my guy Mike he was like
I'm gonna get y'all I'm gonna give y'all
a chance to bring y'all stuff in here
and we like all right cool yeah they're
expanding it looks great are they doing
anything yeah is it a meet and greet at
their uh La store so it was probably CCC
yup yup yeah on 7th Street yeah yeah
because it was dtpg I would have saw the
flyer and [__] you would have told me to
come through okay all right for sure we
appreciate you see what happens about
the strain then we started talking about
Google
it's okay I appreciate you being here I
appreciate you thank you thank you for
being here thank you sir Marty thank you
for being here guys this has been the
dope as usual podcast this has been the
ad episode for Marty ad and I have a
dope ass day boom
um
I'm like this
[Music]